suchte monster und fand alter 2-coup auf
einmal weg
hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen adventure map
alle die die mir bei facebook folgen bzw
dort gelebt haben wissen dass sich dort
gefragt habe ob ich mal wieder ein
adventure aufnehmen soll ihm meinte
tulloch so ziemlich ja mach das mal und
da habe ich mir gedacht dass ich mir die
map zweifel desert race beziehungsweise
desert wasteland aussuche also dass es
eine wüste nmap die hat bisher nur ganz
ganz wenige downloads jetzt noch fast
kein youtuber gemacht und ich habe mir
gedacht ich packe noch sind action pack
rheinwasser zeigen ganz gut passt das
sieht alles ein bisschen deshalb ein
bisschen trist aus mit dem default
expect deswegen hab ich mir das wieder
geholt das sonst mutiges texture pack
werde ich eventuell auch bald vorstellen
wenn ihr das wollt
und ja wir sind in einer wüste gefangen
das einzige was wir haben ist hier lava
da ein bisschen gras wir haben hier live
anderen live oder live an der live genau
das leben unter dem leben und einen baum
halt hier müssen dann einfach das
prinzip ist so ein bisschen ähnlich wie
bei skype blog wir haben halt weniger
ressourcen
wir haben fast nur sand hier und sonst
halt das hier und ich werde noch mal
ganz kurz den sound ein wenig runter
drehen weil es noch ein bisschen nervig
und wir müssen halt mit diesem paar
sachen hier auskommen ich würde sagen
dass wir einfach mal direkt anfangen und
uns ein paar dinge holen übrigens was
ich sagen wollte war
bitte bitte bitte schreibt mir in die
kommentare bzw bewertet das video mit
einen daumen hoch wenn ihr wollt dass
dieses projekt weitergeht mit einem
daumen runter wenn ihr sagten noch nicht
weiter weil ich werde jetzt eine folge
aufnehmen werde auf die resonanz warten
also wie das ankommen wird und dann
entscheide ich das halt ob ihr das video
gut findet oder schlecht findet ob ich
das weitermachen soll oder nicht
ich denke dass es im interesse von allen
also ihr dürft bestimmen ob ich das
weitermachen soll oder nicht
und ich kann auch mal ganz kurz die noch
ein paar sachen vorlesen und zwar erst
mal die regeln wir dürfen nicht sterben
ein richtiger spieler spielt aber das
ganze jahr auf hardcore aber ich finde
ich möchte die welt nachher zum download
freigeben wenn das projekt vorbei wenn
wir die ganzen challenges fertig haben
und dann bringt es nichts wenn ich jetzt
auf hardcore spiel und die welt ist dann
nachher weg wenn ich das beende das dann
irgendwie ein bisschen ungünstig
deswegen spielt das grab hier auf sie
dann leitet timo trotz also keine single
player kommt alles nicht drin ich werde
auch nicht schießen welt das ganze
aufnehme und wir sollen wenigstens auf
die sie spielen damit wir den zugang zu
allen möglichen items haben wie zum
beispiel monster drops und so weiter und
eine challenge ist übrigens eine monster
falle bauen.com wir da gar nicht drum
rum ich habe das auf easy gestellt dann
gibt es noch hier die challenges die
lese ich auch mal ganz kurz vor wir
dürfen nicht sterben also das war auch
schon regeln wir müssen einen koffer
stone generate abbauen wir müssen eine
monster falle bauen
wir müssen eigentlich übersetzt man
gerade eine unendliche wasserquelle
müssen wir haben ein wir müssen überall
in der wüste sichere wegpunkte setzen
damit wir die ein bisschen erkunden
können ohne dass wird dabei jetzt total
die orientierung verlieren
ich möchte dass jemand ein paar sätzen
herunterfallen wir müssen ein haus bauen
wir müssen uns eine eine fackel kräften
einen stonebridge sollen wir uns machen
besonders wolle kräften wahrscheinlich
irgendwie aus strings oder so wir sollen
mehr lava finden als nur die hier also
irgendwo anders auch noch lava wir
sollen erde von noch zwei zusätzlichen
orten finden also wenn bisher nur hier
erde gefunden es gibt er dennoch
woanders wir sollen die oase finden was
man darunter vorstellen kann ist glaube
ich jedem bewusst also einer wüste halt
so eine kleine landschaft wo man denkt
dass das eine fata morgana ist wegen wie
so eine zuckerarme sollen wir machen wir
sollen eine kaktus fall meine melonen
fahre meine weizen farm eine pilz fahren
und eine kuhherde sollen wir auch noch
anlocken und dann wärs dass auch
eigentlich schon wenn hier kein setzling
runterkommen zahnweh schon verpackt aber
schon ein setzen einfach mal hierhin ich
hoffe da kommt noch ein zweiter raus
oder so weil sonst wäre das echt
ärgerlich
ja ok guthaben nur ein müssen wir nur
hoffen dass da dann irgendwie dem
nächsten baum braucht wechselt wenn es
fünf holz und ich würde sagen müssen
echt total vorsichtig damit irgendwie
und ich sprinte ja auch schon die ganze
zeit damit muss sich auch vorsichtig
sein
ich würde sagen dass wir das ganze hier
gleich erstmal erkunden ich habe hier
schon die erde ein bisschen weggenommen
also sind haben wir genug aber ich denke
mal dass also auf jeden fall eine
workbench brauchen wir auf jeden fall
sticks auch so und noch eins für ein
paar sachen wir werden uns erst mal eine
schaufel eine schaufel schaufel für
schaufel weiß gar nicht womit überhaupt
immer und ich will zeigen mit
bundesregierung gefährden aus dann kann
man sich natürlich schlecht häuser bauen
deswegen werde ich das ganze aus sense
dauern machen und dafür mache ich mir
allerdings erstmal eine spitzhacke damit
wir hier so sofort ein paar gute acht
wir können hier direkt denkens mitnehmen
fällt mir gerade oft müssen wir nicht so
viel sand wollen naja also jetzt kann
ich ja auch mal jetzt haben wir hier die
ganzen sachen erst mal ach nee dat kann
ich auch noch voll ist und zwar gibt es
noch zu entschuldigen das ist halt der
erste part muss man immer ein paar
sachen wollen blabla es gibt noch
storyline challenges also die die ich
gerade vorgelesen habe das waren für die
normalen challenges die man so machen
kann beziehungsweise muss und da gibt es
auch sachen die muss man nicht unbedingt
machen aber die sind halt von der story
hier abhängig und zwar lernen wir die
story dadurch sage ich mal
und zwar habe ich die nicht auf deutsch
übersetzt und entlädt sich einfach mal
so auf englisch vor ich weiß auch nicht
ob ich die alle noch machen werde
einfach mal schauen wie lange ich bock
auf dieses projekt ab wenn ich auch
irgendwann sage ja okay für die und die
sache braucht man jetzt vielleicht noch
30 tage einfach nur hier dran rum sitzt
und abbauen
da wird auch kein motto was ich mache
das einfach wirklich so lange es mir
spaß macht so lange es euch spaß macht
und dann ist alles gut also die
storyline challenges sind mann soll hand
cover die horus live test
wie finden oder so discovergy horst
buddy das cover the gift of how des
covers training browns und discover the
hope osbourne und camp ich weiß nicht
genau was damit jetzt alles gemeint ist
ich mache mich erst mal so eine farm hin
aber wie gesagt ich würde sagen
gerichtet uns erstmal nach den haupt
challenges und theoretisch könnte es
kommen wenn wir schon dabei sind alles
vorzulesen lese ich euch auch noch mal
ein paar tipps vor und zwar street ist
halt represent the way the grass
transporter verstehe ich nicht
also der meint wohl dass wir irgendwie
hier dingens haben sollen machen tun
irgendwie so wasser sollte wohl irgendwo
der nähe sein
allerdings habe ich das jetzt noch nicht
gesehen und die oase soll angeblich auch
ziemlich nah hier dran sein
ich würde sagen wir nehmen uns erst mal
die erde weg vielleicht ist darunter ja
irgendwo noch was ich habe keine ahnung
ach da ist dann ist das sehr schön das
must-have belong to someone egmr schild
mal schauen was so eine kiste drin ist 8
wasikowska war gleich mitnehmen
cool ich dachte schon irgendwie hier
wäre so keine kiste oder so und wer
hätte schon total verpackt als ich ja
doch alles zum guten gewendet also
airways ihren autos dort steht hier look
around for more als out wer also wenn
wir einmal keine erde mehr haben sondern
einfach ein bisschen rumlaufen irgendwo
ist noch erde soll es gar keine sorgen
machen da steht noch lava ist baute
tanks auf kilometer um kilometer way
from you but it is really hard days
night remember the locator 317 wir uns
das will come up with the monsters okay
gut also es gibt keine höhlen es gibt
nirgendwo höhlen
das heißt wir müssen es gibt
wahrscheinlich auch keine ärzte denke
ich nur außerdem irgendwo welche
versteckt oder wir müssen einfach so
zurecht kommen und ich würde sagen wir
machen es erstmal auch den einmal haben
wir dann können uns direkt die lava
damit nehmen worauf wollen wir den kopf
von generali monika wer theoretisch
irgendwo draußen lassen
gut das glas theoretisch hat mir gerade
auch auffällt wir können uns eigentlich
auch darunter abbauen dann wieder so ein
bisschen glas und das viel zu
kompliziert
so den kommission generell habe ich
einfach hierhin ich hoffe ich kann das
noch von sky block mit dena das ist ja
total schief gegangen ist so schön so
jetzt können wir abbauen theoretisch
auch wenn wir sehen wir sollen ja eine
infinite water source wie wollen wir das
eigentlich machen
ich werde dafür brauchen wir noch mal
wasser zwei fischer weise kann auch noch
nicht was ist das bringt mich nimmt
erstmal hier im park pistons mit so der
macht jetzt eine kommission pc's und
danach ist auch schon die ersten acht
und dann müssen wir ganz ganz vorsichtig
sein ich glaube die last an unsere
einzige beleuchtung die wir haben
aber wir können der theoretisch holz mit
holz ab online der baum ist nicht
gewachsen
wenn du schon kaputt so irgendwann
werden wir kein holz mehr haben denn wir
müssen richtig hoffen dass der baum
richtig schnell wächst oder wir müssen
direkt skelette töten dass wir dann
bäume wachsen und so dies das so jetzt
haben wir das hat man sich viel habe ich
eigentlich zwei von oven braucht man 3 4
5 6 7 8
wasser schon sieben ok 8 stellen auf
machen organisiert schon nach dem
schrecklich eine fackel brauche ich
mindestens so wird man wie mache ich das
denn jetzt okay gut
ein kohle kommt daraus ein kohle ein
verdammtes kohle braucht man sticks habe
ich auch keine mehr dampf damit so die
vier torch ist okay gut fordert wird
richtig schwer
ich sag's euch ich möchte dass ihr alles
mal eben ein bisschen aus daneben ging
hier ist ausgeleuchtet und hier noch am
besten braucht ja irgendwie ein schwert
oder sowas
aber ich weiß nicht da oben sind schon
die zombies sind in diesem text peking
wie komisch sind körperlos also da sind
dann einfach nur so köpfe das muss ich
noch ein bisschen überarbeiten da hinten
ist schon skelett ich weiß ich sollte
eins liegt dafür verwenden jacob grimm
machen ein mein gott einst ich hoffe
dass dann ist der baum noch gewachsen
dann mache ich eben schwer tun dann
können wir sofort ein paar monster
kloppen gehen halt aber anna janina
nenne ich habe eine kiste so ich würde
sagen da unser sport noch direkt hier
ist können wir eigentlich direkt los
ziehen oder ich mach mal ganz kurz und
seine art house wenn das haus nennen
kann man hier so den eingang
so kann man auch schon mal lassen so als
haus dann trägst du hier einfach noch
ein bisschen merkt ja keiner tür
brauchen wir noch ich mein man braucht
für alles holz ist es einfach so dass es
einfach ist halt minecraft weil man da
war doch noch
immer noch sammeln macht man den einfach
so ermitteln gut drei hoch du kannst
dann theoretisch auch wieder weg damit
ich das hier noch im monster sind da
hinten letzten krieg gottchen online
ich hoffe da drin uns auch keiner malta
das einzige was ich als gesprächsthemen
habe sektoren ist keine bereich auf
deren ist keiner
wir werden sofort losgehen und es wird
auch in den nächsten potsdam spannender
werden dass amazon anfang skype blog am
anfang ist auch übels sind einfach weil
halt nichts machen kannst ist halt so
kann jetzt auch nichts gegen sagen ist
einfach so das müsste eigentlich reichen
wenn vernünftiges dach haus dingsbums
wisst ihr was wir verleihen dem ganzen
ein wenig touch indem wir einfach die
die gingen south machen
doch noch schnell zu ende
man wisse was auch passiert ich werde
hundertprozentig spawn monster auf
unserem dach
das kann ich jetzt schon sagen so die
fackel sich mal hier hin da drin sollte
eigentlich alles ausgeleuchtet sein kann
damit direkt im haus kommission john
ritter hier ist auch schön am laufen
wir kommen also ich pack das jetzt mal
weg und gehen bei monster kloppen ganz
allein in der wüste streifte er umher
suchte monster und fand alter 2-coup auf
einmal lieber weg ach du scheiße ich hab
ja gut ich habe hier so viel sand und so
viele krieg ich kann mir richtig viel
tnt machen was man das bringt ja das
werdet ihr dann erfahren so noch einmal
panschen glaube ich verhältnisses
skelett das brauchen wir für volvo nicht
nur ins bett
ich möchte irgendwie hierhin los du
kommst man mit druck hat es auch schon
ändern männer immer weg auch gut
guck da seht ihr links ohne krone körper
ist ihr wasser nicht ob da hinten ist
auch ihnen was sie zu verdächtig combos
aus da kommt eine spinne an
aber wie schon mehrmals gesagt wenn wir
sterben ist nicht weiter schlimm
dann sind auch schon mal so hora wenn
wir sterben es wirklich nicht weiter
schlimm weil wir den sportback ich da
hinten haben und ich werde mich auch nie
wirklich sehr weit davon weg bewegen
denke ich war okay nach und nach müssen
wir uns weiter weg bewegen aber werde
mich werd mich hier getroffen er nach
und nach müssen uns weiter weg bewegen
damit einfach ein paar neue sachen
finden wie zum beispiel erde müssen wir
finden da oben ist auch noch irgendwas
drauf da muss ich auch nochmal hoch
laufen
ich würde sagen wir gehen das mal ganz
kurz zurück einfach mal schauen was
daraus wird
also ich würde auch sagen ich mache
jetzt erst mal einen kleinen auch
cantauw ich bin jedem ich bin tot ok
besten direkt ihren weg weg weg weg weg
weg weg weg weg sachen gott dass er noch
hier die wird männer a
stirb so ein herz voller liebe hätte ich
mich töten lassen na gut gibt erstmal
meine sachen wieder kann ich den pfeil
aufsammeln 85 eilig haben bogen vom
skelett pokal darüber jetzt hier ist
jeder töten hier müsste krippe und wer
erstmal sollte ich mein leben generell
komme ich so nah zu mir ich soll doch
alles heile bleiben auch jetzt wieder so
einen zombie gut also
bisher habe ich endlich keine sorgen um
essen oder so nur ich habe mir macht mir
angst um holz dass da kein setzling
rauskommt wenn er zwei setzlinge
rauskommen ist alles wunderbar
aber wenn er gar keiner raus kommt du
dann dann dann ja dann ne handelt sich
aber was los du so ich nehme ein paar
pfeile mit wir noch ein bisschen weiter
panschen gehen wisst ihr was ich mache
jetzt erstmal ein stopp für diese folge
wie ich schon am anfang erwähnt schreibt
mir einen kommentar ob es weiter haben
wollt bzw am einfachsten ist es wirklich
gibt dem video einen daumen hoch wenn
ihr zweiter haben wollte und einen
daumen runter wenn ihr sagten bricht
sofort ab ist kacke und dann würde ich
einfach sagen sehen uns dann eventuell
in part 2